now I've been super candid I've always
spoken up uh about how for the first
season of Jackass I made less than 1500
bucks oh yeah same oh yeah like
I think the band did like really well
because he kind of came in as a producer
like he had the whole CKY thing going I
was uh it was like a 250 or 300 per
stunt and we went to Florida where I met
you and I came back and I had like 15
stunts and Tripp Taylor called me in and
said we have made a change it's now
three stunts for 300 bucks oh yeah and
and by then it was the second season
yeah paid per stunt on the second oh
yeah absolutely absolutely you got
screwed because they uh we all got
screwed all right they
um you know after the second season all
right I'm sorry I have the first season
aired and I'd made the per stunt bit but
then they paid me 2 000 per episode on
the second season and the third season
did they pay you up front or just like
on a weekend hop up front wow and and so
after taxes uh half up front was uh ten
thousand bucks now if I didn't go on the
road with you I would I would have been
in a bill to make it you know try this
at home tour or yeah yeah no and I had a
job driving a limousine at that time and
I had a took some people out on the town
had a great time went great and then all
of a sudden they called and said hey
um we just noticed that that was one of
the guys from Jackass on there we
thought we were going to be prank we'd
like our money back and my boss is like
you are fired and you can't do this no
way and I was like I'm grabbing great
service had a good time but they just
started thinking about it I was like
wait a minute we could get this whole
thing for free you know oh damn so I was
fired from the limousine business hold
some porn people around though that was
pretty interesting oh yeah because you
got to the airport and pick him up and
they're just bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed and you go and they spend a
week in Hollywood usually like five days
then that limousine right back to go to
Ohio or Michigan was a sad deal they had
the little bit of Shame yeah it's a
little shame and they also do 250 300
percent
I'm in the same same painting there
America if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do I have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
The Bucket List tour and the stuff I
filmed for this show is way too hot for
Jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy Olympics and
skyjacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]